und ab auf den schädel könnte auch mal
zu hause machen einfach mal auf den
schädel von ihrem papi zb drauf springen
hopp rufen und dann wird er schon
verstehen wenn ich in ein wassersauger
trotzdem noch ein
da war doch noch was
check point maracle
was soll da kann ich all dies maria und
du weisst was das ist
das hier ist es dasselbe wie das da
nicht machen wenn es mal noch nein ich
bin so schlecht mein minecraft ruckelt
in letzter zeit so derbe ich weiß nicht
woran das liegt einfach nur wenig die
shader drin habe aber nicht mehr
nicht mal an habe ruckelt das schon
ich bin doch ich habe mir bleibt endlich
mal eine neue grafikkarte
dann bin ich eigentlich zufrieden dank
an alle die mir bei meiner facebook
seite dazu da geholfen haben welche
grafikkarte ich nehmen soll welche gutes
ist die gtx 680 seinen alle die
interesse daran haben legen wir wissen
damit was anfangen zu können weiß ich
nicht keine ahnung
mit 2 gb
ich hatte auch noch richtig auf hat dann
das war so nah dran solar
nein wird man so blattmann seid ihr
nicht merkt die maps cool
hey wir wollen jetzt hat mir das
überhaupt gerade irgendetwas gebracht
hier her zu springen
frage ich mich gerade mal so ich glaube
nicht nee ich glaube gar nichts mal ganz
kurz darunter ist irgendwann der ist ja
nicht mehr oder doch
ich bin sofort darum man schalter
wahrscheinlich um die lobby tür
aufzumachen
ab
bergstedt
hier stießen die aussichtsplattformen
danke für ihren besuch unseres service
büros haben nun geöffnet
unsere motivierten mitarbeiter stehen
ihnen zur frage und antwort ach ja wir
haben ein feuer auf dem kurszettel
begeben sie sich zu den notausgängen
ding noch unser klingels kaputten herds
müsstest du funktionieren also service
hat offenbar die büroräume wenn ich bin
spontan erblindet ach so habe keine lust
suchen meine kontaktlinsen
es sind meine schreibtisch pflanze mir
ist langweilig bin weg aber heute
geburtstag und mache frei rolle gerade
neues papier kaufen gerade ein
ich hasse euch hallo ich spreche aus dem
fenster bin eben auf dem klo bin gerade
nicht da feier heute krank habe mich
erhängt suchen einen stuhl wenn in der
mittagspause
und jetzt muss ich wiederum jumpen oder
wie
da geht es auf jeden fall nicht lange
ihr habt da muss ich für ist
wahrscheinlich wiederum könnten
sowohl an den mädels ein totenkopf das
ist auf jeden fall schon mal sehr
einladend aus
und hier aber und da drauf
und ab auf den schädel könnte auch mal
zu hause machen einfach mal auf den
schädel von europa wie zum beispiel
darauf springen abrufen und dann wird
das schon verstehen was sie damit
bezwecken wollte
notausgang notausgang mal so wenn ich
ihnen jetzt hier ach jetzt bin ich hier
oben drauf der fluchtweg fährt über den
baum tolles konzept nicht herum das ist
sehr cool
ja da ist es mein karte bestimmt
wir sind überall mainka trauer
ach so das sind keine mein platz ist in
not cards natürlich ja klar mit sehr
logisch
uns parat
so fahren wie man hier lange hier not
platzieren und reinsetzen 24 feste druff
es brennt
sound hat sich im komm schon so wirklich
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt aber
nicht sagen
gb
guten tag sie sind auf dem fluchtweg zum
sammelplatz halten sie die hände im
wagen und atmen sie gleichmäßig enders
weiter
falls es nicht weitergeht müssen sie
ihre karte
okay ganz einfach
weiter gehts ja
es geht weiter es gibt weiter ich merkte
loris geht weiter wollen sie vielleicht
eintritt etwas trinken haben wir haben
viele drinks im angebot jeder drink
kostet 9000 geld trinkgeld nicht
inbegriffen weiter so so eine fahrt nur
verkehrt ist ganz schön ist ganz ist
schon ganz schön anstrengend nicht war
anstrengend wird mit geschrieben oder
ich weiß es nicht mehr total verliert
wollen sie vielleicht ein bisschen
jessica lang musik zu jessica lang musik
für aus kommt aus dem handbuch für die
wahl des richtigen notausgangs benötigen
sie das plus von 86
das passwort 86 finden sie im handbuch
für die wahl des richtigen notausgang
hotel hurra wir sind im center für
notausgänge wie können zwischen die web
notausgänge hellen viel glück 9 34 93
vettel
das sieht nicht gut aus sie auch nicht
gut das sieht nicht so gut aus
egal nimmst du scheiß egal
gute wahl ja ich weiß danke ja das ist
ein pinker dampfender haufen popo freude
ich wo also oder oder dieses publikum
ist purist der kacke glaub ich oder ich
weiß nicht dass allah liste nicht das
allerbeste aber es schon das beste aber
nicht dass alles so lange
mama die kleine schäm dich ecke okay da
geht es nicht lang vergessen
fluchtweg ok ok flüchte da sind holen
moment verwirrt uns da brennt was an so
sammelpunkt warten sich auf rettung
warten auf hilfe warten auf hilfe warten
auf hilfe
gbr gehen sie müssen das feuer löschen
wir haben keine lust unser leben aufs
spiel zu setzen
ich höre mein karl selbst wenn das feuer
löschen ich komme aber niemals auf oder
komme ich da drauf wie sollte ich da
drauf kommen muss ich dann irgendwie
hoch ja ich muss das feuer löschen aber
wie ist die frage hätte ich schon mal
kurz hinter kann ich hier nicht
irgendwie kann ich auch nicht aus auch
nix schau mal hier nochmal nach hab ich
vielleicht irgendetwas übersehen habe
auch ich habe noch viele aber damit kann
ich nicht viel anfangen
hier sieht es aus als ob sie hochgeht
oder auch nicht nein das sieht er nicht
so aus da geht es doch glaube ich nicht
rum oder ist ein schild ein schild ein
schild an der wand etwas geht ich heiße
marie ok cool war es hakt schon wieder
so derbe funkel schon die ganze zeit
irgendwie heftig guckt euch das mal an
19 apps wieso habe ich nun habe ich nur
so wenig ps naja
muss man mit leben so ich schon einmal
ganz kurz nach wie kann ich das denn
schaffen die sonne geht auch schon
wieder runter ist sehr sehr bild ich
muss das feuer löschen schöne barbie um
simpkins ich musste irgendwie hochkommen
ich habe keine ahnung ich muss ja
irgendwie hoch habe ich weiß nicht wie
vielleicht muss ich ja durchs mainka
zurück aber ich kann leider auch nie
mehr hoch durch meine katze rücken
wieder stehen bleiben oder so aber ich
komme aus dem gang auch nicht raus zu
nehmen was kaputt zu machen
sie warten auf hilfe warten auf hilfe
vielen dank für ihre geduld die
rettungskräfte sind geflüchtet
gw ergänzt sie müssen das feuer löschen
wir haben alle keine lust unser leben
aufs spiel zu setzen
ja wenn ich wüsste wie ich das feuer
löschen könnte dann wird dies auch
machen
na ja ich würde sagen immer erst mal
hier in aufnahme stopp
wenn ihr weiter wisst ich das machen
könnte könnte es mir einfach unten in
die kommentare schreiben da werde ich
euch sehr verbunden drüber und dann
werde ich das mal ausprobieren und ich
hoffe da ganz auf eure mithilfe und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal wie
immer wenn jetzt gut findet könnt ihr
einfach einen daumen hoch geben das
würde mich sehr freuen
und dann sieht es beim nächsten mal
tschüss